hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to what might be the
conclusion of n the story
god I love amnesia so much okay anyway
just had to throw that out there hey
what happened to you dammit
Oh looks like there might be a little
more than I thought there was okay yeah
that's enough you don't need to be
sliding all over the floor with me I see
some blue over there not sure what
that's ah more blue I love me some
beauty but you know you're getting
towards the end when they're they start
to use the Bluth fire
oh why is that thing so tall Oh guys so
tall oh oh don't don't move don't move
don't move don't move don't move
ha ha ha oh god it's so many of them ha
ha ha oh this is good have to dig
something whoa hello oh yeah that's a
it's a bad idea I know this this bag is
alright fine
oh listen Peas Emma
that's uh that's cute now give me out
let me out let me out there we go a
whoosh super jump
ha ha Emma alright that's not a
gravestone Deborah Coleman mother and
wife you will be missed I know so the
father made a grave for Emma Kate
Edwards beloved family friend and al
worthington loyal button oh oh no oh no
run ha ha ha don't need to tell me no no
no no no nope nope no I say no get out
of here ooh ah
can't get okay so what is this deal I
need a I need to find a lever to get
that I don't think I saw a lover when
that thing was chasing me
oh ha ha ha ha baby ah ladies how you
doing the only statues that I am not
completely terrified of whoa
sailors sailors what the huh what
sailors Oh this is part of that this is
part of this potentia and I had no idea
what it was about
we're failures like some support we're
failures supposed to be like a currency
and um in the original amnesia are they
actually a thing I had no idea I so cool
can I use these tailors on this chest
hello baby can you open that little
chest there for me please darling
ah keys in here wow that's okay you're
fine just the way you are oh so fine but
not as fine some ladies out there none
of that another that deep lip lip
all I ever wanted to do was to do good
my experiments was supposed to help the
human race oh god what have I become a
monster
oh how how did I do that dog food lunch
with my fists of fury aha hello lady
just a busted-up in this chest when it
exploded oh how convenient that is that
way well now let's not dilly-dally we've
got an ending to find or see not find
because it's right there I'm not going
back that way
Oh what is that no mementos are
available even though I just wrote one I
saw it gah wait one no no ha ha shut up
father I already blew up your arm
no Pablo who's
Raja Raja Raja hello father
who's there speak up nope um yeah oh is
that my is that my boyfriend
hello I never sent that letter oh oh oh
well I'm just happy did you see your
father's more than the origin I crashed
it wait you did what Oh No ah Nagar guy
okey dokey you you all stop making me
focus right on your penis your father
thought it was dead ha now thanks to you
I don't have to worry about that
okey dokey
try not to look so cool it just looked
good at that pretty face of yours
ah good you say pretty favorable he's
perfect as I expected with my dog to do
and deal you played your party now who
says since the picture yeah
Alexander's got my back her naked floaty
guy force from the write a letter crying
for a helper with instructions to
destroy mmm other guys told me to
destroy the orc aah my oil all my oil
pure yay it's all fixed to you you're
welcome
so thank you
enjoyable short time I have worked
okey-dokey ow what did you do you break
my legs
how could you Father I trusted you oh oh
I'm a story part one ha ha oh wait Neal
Winkler created it but no Neal was used
to boyfriend Wow ha ha ha oh man rogem
even though you've only made it past one
level without crying come on rich em get
your [ __ ] together anyway that was an
awesome mod that was that was amazing I
don't know why that wasn't so highly
rated I mean I mean that's incredible
Oh Emma's signal oh that makes sense
Neal and Emma Emma Neal and Vanille a
dilemma oh come on you can't make this
good custom story and then not continue
with it ever oh all right so anyway that
was a really really really really well
done mod I don't know why that wasn't
high more highly rated those phenomenal
I mean honestly it's hard to find good
mods and that was phenomenal so I hope
you all enjoyed that that mannequin part
was the worst ever and if you don't know
what I'm talking about see the last part
cuz it was kind of bad so anyway thank
you guys so much for watching click the
links over there in the annotations to
see more videos that I've done click the
reaction compilation down below if you
want the whole playlist it's right down
there so thank you so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye